[Music]
and welcome back everybody to an amazing
off the Record where today we are in the
most beautiful office that we are so
proud to be a part of and we hope the
fans actually like it this time okay yes
thank you we don't care if you do cuz
we're not changing it back yeah we're
not changing it back and we know what
you did last time you called [__]
sellouts [__]
you these are like meanwhile totally
different fans I know I those ones [__]
those ones if you're subscrib though
thank you but that last set was bad
though so I agree actually no [__] me go
okay I didn't like the set either what
do you some people have told me they
like that set are you talking about the
revamped news set the glowy set the big
one the big ass one at the downtown
office it was like a professional it
didn't bother them that much but that's
also like you guys had to sit and like
talk to each other sideways yeah I
didn't like that I also didn't like how
it was fake it's like a Vicon panel
you're like yeah yeah yeah it's crazy
well this one is real cuz you can still
play pool side
yeah if you're if you're good this one's
real because you can feel that there was
someone who understood this and put it
together not a depressed lady who was
like in her Dark Times m is that who
designed the last one that's what he
said yeah that was the office okay so
that's real [__] we hired a lot of bad
on professional help here's our question
for the day in what way would you most
like to become famous in what way I
thought we famous yeah I thought we your
your opportunity to answer certain
things like making a cure for a cancer
or some [__] that's cool you you think
you think Nelson do you think Nelson
Mandela has guys trying to Jack him try
to jack it Nelson Mandela no his that's
the kind of Fame is good so like or
Morgan Freeman so like the kind of Fame
that you want is like Nobel Peace Prize
Fame you don't want like like not even
that he does even that's name a Nobel
Peace Prize winner how about how about
best gym 2024
mandal all right not even that what that
attracts C Ty on behal of themselves
first so we can get clear bearing and
then we can start I want to do this to
every deflector cuz you going to deflect
into some yeah we might as well take the
first seven minutes for that if I had to
pick something that I was going to be
famous for it would have to be I would
like it to be the work that I do you so
your your business training people if I
had to pick one thing it would it would
I would rather goes public on the New
York Stock Market maybe not that but
like in the ways that you see how
trainers can uh like blow up there's
like celebrity TV trainers there's
people that just have crazy apps that
make like six seven figures a month like
in what way would you like to be I think
to be able to help more people right
like in the way of like okay I have I
could build a big audience or something
I guess if I had to pick one with thing
yeah that'll probably be it I I don't
think I'd ever be like like a celebrity
trainer I don't think that I don't think
that's the route you don't want to teach
the rock how to do things the [__] am I
going to teach the rock dude how to do
things real naked choke how to deflect
yeah no but like you know the people
that actually probably need it you know
the people that would actually need
health and fitness help like disabled
people but they're the worst cuz they
complain and [__] maybe you could be
known for helping people who overshare
deflect you're sharing too much do it
like this ask the question three more
times when you meet someone don't tell
them your life story play a little hard
again yeah look at me look at me look
see I'm not saying anything just be
enter a state of mind where you think
anything you say is not interesting yeah
yeah yeah and that's that's how I go oh
you know you know what I would like I
like the fame that Adam Sandler has oo
that's cool he's a famous guy but he's
famous for not acting like a famous guy
it's true oh cuz you see him just
playing basketball just wearing regular
clothes regular guy people give him a
shirt and they're like this is my kid
softball team and then the next day he's
wearing it on like TMZ and [__] so dope
that is actually so like Keo Reeves yeah
I mean or like how like how Adam Sandler
went to IHOP and they couldn't see him
and he's like okay well thanks we'll go
somewhere else like that's so sick dude
what if you're at IH out though and
you're Adam sley like talk to the
[__] manager do you know who the
[__] I would have to do it there that's
the only place I would ever do that like
there's no way you haven't seen Mr Deeds
come on that's [__] crazy they didn't
just bust out us spare table I'm like Mr
Sandler please right here but that's
like cuz he's trying to teach his
daughter like the respect and stuff like
it's funny because you technically don't
have to change cuz you could just be
yourself everyone expects you to be an
[__] but you're really still you you
get credit for it now that's pretty cool
kind dope Adam Sandler Kevin James and
um uh uh Rob Schneider they they came to
my restaurant that I was was a bus bus
boy at and then um we had to get a
security to kind of like Velvet Rope
around them cuz people were trying to
bother them and then when they finished
they said bye to every person staff
everybody said thank you to all the
staff and then they left so dope every
single
person a bunch of losers put a Velvet
Rope what a I like the idea of being
famous for not acting like a famous guy
that's cool I like that that's probably
the best case scenario right no yours
was I don't think so helping millions of
people across the world fix their knee
problems why is that that's not
deflecting dude [__] you what would you
do Anthony Lee yeah what would you do
you want to be the world's best dancer
in the world face is that face you look
like you're Plugged In The Matrix on the
one hand uh no I wouldn't want to be
famous for dance because then I think it
would unlike Nick you already are famous
for dance true you can't beat Michael
Jackson I think it would like perpetuate
me needing to work in that space whereas
like it would be dope to be quote
unquote so successful that I would I
wouldn't have to dance for work you know
what I'm saying I dance for dance for
money anymore yeah yeah dance for money
for dollar bills so so on the more
logical what's actually within the realm
I would love to be [__] famous for JK
news which would mean that we' be
killing it so hard cuz right now right
now we're very like maybe like zclass
we're middling we my brains but you are
the Jackson Wang of JK for sure that's
racist I thought he would wanted to be a
noodle man I thought that's what I
thought the whole time a noodle
distributor shoe cobbler I that too a
car salesman take out
mochan I mean I like M shine oh yeah why
would you want them to close what you're
doing cut that out cut that out B that's
that's why kbang all day baby okay but
you know what I mean like if I was like
if I was super famous for JK news that
probably be like maybe our salaries are
bumped right back up wow you're really
you're really thinking outside of
yourself that's really cool well when
you think about it this is I think for
most of us I I think I'm speaking for
all of us this is the most fun thing
that we all do absolutely so yeah I
think being known for this place is a
good
answer too slow
sucker you still ow me that shot go get
it right now recover recovery get it
Nick cuz you suck at Street Fighter that
have to take a shot he does have to take
a shot and I'm collecting on it mid
video because he dissed me and I'm
offended no I agree though oh you're not
here you say like being known for dance
just leads to more dance and
being famous for dance sucks ass when
you imagine being every time you're
where anybody's dancing you get that
[__] shove on the small of your back
and people are like get in there smoke
that guy do your thing like that's old
even when you're not a dancer that's
annoying so now I know what to do to
Ryan bro well no because you you there
is there is that connotation of the
dance monkey dance syndrome that happens
when you're like but are you like I
don't even do Crump and then they still
push you and you're like I'm a break it
doesn't even matter yeah it's so weird
that only certain professions get that
cuz it's not like if you have like two
podcasters like Joe Rogan Lex Freeman
just start talking yeah just start
talking just talk I just want to hear
yeah but if they say you're a comic
you're like tell me a joke I'm sure that
yeah I'm sure that happens with
magicians too magicians probably be like
hey do a trick you know you know what
you got to say you're a writer cuz no
one's going to say o get a pen of paper
[__] write write for me you said
you're a writer cuz I was like I am even
cooler or riding on a bck right I'm a
rider dude
rider that's a lot of work so much work
for Ryan yeah Ryan has to take up take
off his [__] pants dry skin right now
there how do I moisturize this thing I
will say that there was that High School
s me that fantasized about being famous
for like you know saving somebody oh
yeah that's Co just being like a one
time Action Hero that's every male dream
though every guy that especially in that
group when you're in high school you're
like if I saved someone's life all these
girls would want me yeah yeah when
someone goes like this the sword and you
go like
that like oh dude home dude [__] that
stopped the shooter at the monter park
dance studio yeah granted I don't
remember his name right now but we know
what he did Brandon right and he's a JK
fan yeah he really John's cookie place
yeah and it's not like it's not like we
run into him we're like Yo dude stop
this shooter you know what I mean it's
just like yo you did a [__] solid
though he he that guy is so cool where
were you cuz he's so real when I ran
into him I was like yo that [__] scary
as [__] he was like [__] yeah dude cuz
you think like no dude [__] took him
out whatever he's like no I was [__]
shaking man that's [__] scary the
scariest [__] of my life I was like damn
I wish he would come on JK so Joe could
have told him what he should have done
better yep I'll tell you you [__]
weak [__] first
civil I think there's two ways which
achieve the same level of Fame for me
that I would go is one is the world
peace route and the other one is
destruction to World Peace route
destruction to world peace is like the
ultimate backs space of the world it's
like a a UNIF they call them like
unifying Kings but really they're just
the king that won a massive region and
there's no competition that's why
there's peace right the United lamb
killed Millions oh I see what you mean
like the first [__] warlord of Japan
it's called the Shogun that unified the
whole Island right or like I don't know
Alexander the Great he's kind of great
cuz he UniFi but it's such a long time
ago that you can pillage and and murder
and kind of go into a space and take
over a space and then people go that's
that's tight you know it's a different
time you got to wait maybe a thousand
years from now and then they go dude Joe
the conquer that guy's [__] tight so
because of those reasons I would I would
probably go the more Gandhi route World
Peace like I stood up I made [__]
salt at the sea I didn't let you tax me
you know oh I'm a peaceful protester you
know like you kind of got Godlike status
but you didn't have to cause harm yeah I
like that how come you're not doing
anything in that realm at all there's
nothing to fight for nothing like all no
like everyone's fight for weak ass [__]
like everyone I'm really a girl like you
know like I
know like [__] what is there fight
for not yeah cuz how it's done
everything's they [__] took my ideas
already yeah yeah nobody's Fighting by
anything right now yeah all the big
problems are solved take me back maybe a
hundred years I I can probably find a
few things but right now like the
Spanish influenza is there one you want
to fix for fun no it's like YouTube
right now there's so many [__]
YouTubers already that are famous it's
like they already did it already like
there's no chance for me no passion
project no there's no root for you at
the top there is it that's kind of how I
feel damn dude that's why they call them
social justice Warriors they're like
made fun of cuz there's no real fight
going on they're just fighting for
stupid did you get that it did can you
give that speech on the capitol
mall Capitol Mall yeah it's not called
Capitol Hill well the capitol mall is
like the outside area where JFK where um
Martin Luther King Talked oh by [__]
Abraham Lincoln's the outside party that
[__] is tight imagine all the be there
for you all right oh you mean in the
scene in Forest gun where like Jenny is
like running through the water and [__]
yeah during the Million Man March yeah
oh man oh man what about you
Stephen I mean I always like to choose a
funny option because like it would be
it'd be so absurd to be known is like
it's like hey dude oh you're Steve Green
I'm like yeah and then like dude your
speed running videos are incredible like
[__] Mario 64 in 2 and a half seconds
like that was crazy I'm like thanks
brother yeah but let's get all right
let's get out of here I feel like Steve
would be a Guinness world of records guy
really for like the most useless [__]
yeah like he would fight hard to be like
I'm the guy that does the most [__]
nuts in his mouth like as a troll record
yeah like I got the most peanuts in the
mouth pters in my mouth like made it
stack in crypto so many times and lost
it so many times so many times that's
true and he wants that record more than
actually he wants the
money hey it to me it's all about being
known for the weirdest or dumbest thing
that's funnier to me than like you're
known for like a cool thing it's like I
don't take myself that seriously
first of all you're not a benevolent man
yeah I like that answer I think that I'm
probably on I'm probably riding with
that answer the most out of all of you
so far especially not
you
damn um because yeah that one there's
just it's like you basically said I want
I want to conquer the world but then the
world's not worth conquering anymore
yep makes you think huh yeah it's like
cans here why would you want okay let me
tell you this
genas Khan was a great warrior and at
that time now now you done it at that
time it was a great time to conquer
great time great time yeah no World
Police nobody nobody you just [__] do
it you do whatever you want now what do
they call you
terrorist so you just worried about the
bad press and [__] dude there's too many
nuclear weapons all the propaganda you
got to probably to do too much can we
put like a lower third and just have
like like a cpan
ticker whenever Joe's talking there's a
guy that I think you would really like
it's a real thing that happened um he's
uh he goes around and gives like
speeches at schools because he was like
a Olympic skater for like speed skating
but he only got the gold because
everybody in front of him fell and
crashed into each other he's from
Australia yeah so then he he go he'll go
to schools cuz he's like the only guy
who ever wanton a gold that's [__]
dope that's so sick but then he just
slowly like finished the race after
everybody was already like Zed out and
then he'll go to schools and and talk
and smack was telling about him because
she had to see him speak and she said
that all he says is like you know you
just got to hang in there and and never
give up because uh just never know
that's amazing not trolling but that's
why I think you would like him I love
him he's famous for that probably number
20 but all 19 all fell on the ground say
though because the to me the funniest
choice would be to be like I'm the
fastest man in the world you
if if it's because of that you have to
change it cuz like that's too good he's
a motivational speaker for like still
being in the game even if you're not
winning like cuz you never know when
everyone else might [__] up and you have
no other choice but to choose you right
he's like I was on a we were doing a
relay race and everyone had heart
attacks
dude that's why heart health is really
important that's kind of how I feel
about veterans you know okay I'm scared
a lot of uh the people in World War II a
lot of them are kind of you know with
age passing away and the ones that are
left you just got to find anyone and
it's like you were in World War II and
he goes yeah I delivered mail but you're
were still [__] a soldier in World
War II and it's like all right oh that's
where going he's the last remaining guy
he's he's alive let's so when you see
those the grandpas and wheelchairs with
the hats on you're kind of like yeah but
he probably just delivered the mail and
[__] yeah he probably sliced the roast
beef he's probably the guy that [__]
you know he went to the airplane and he
kind of tighten the nuts and [__] and
then he goes all right do other veterans
make fun of those veterans Bart no oh
okay really no they
actually thank you for keeping our
Airline
safe oh yeah that's
better this this go where am I again hey
keep your hand
down they talk we're in the car wash
yeah but they're super Savvy
verbally
what about you Bart or B I was thinking
about it he hates Fame yeah my first one
is I don't really like to be famous but
then it just so happened we did we had a
lot of fun and then people started
watching it so it's became a side
product so that's pretty cool and I do
like when people like I meet people in
public they like oh dude like you guys
were positive influenc in my life and
I'm like that's sick but now what would
I like to be famous for now I think it'
be I would love to be famous for being
the whatever happened happened to that
guy okay so if there's a point of my if
it gets my point like like they're like
you know how sometimes you go
like that like you like go to the movie
theater too early and like whatever
happened to like when like before the
trailers even start like the quizzes the
trivia like what what's that guy's name
[__] like like whatever happened to
John cusac you know like that what what
happened what happened to Bart they' be
like that like that's you want to be in
a Jo blow video yeah that's joow video
joow Jo Blow YouTube guy he he just did
a video called what happened to John Q
that's why you said that an
investigative video journalist talking
about blowj I think you definitely
latently maybe saw that somewhere and
like that's why you said that today no
cuz I was actually thinking about the
Charles in Charge guy but I forgot his
name
SC he does look
kakan to be a child actor yes where
they're like what happened to him I
don't know move on Jonathan T reality oh
yeah he just resurfaced and he looks
ugly oh no who said that Steve said that
I what about what about like 's dancing
around it would you be down to be famous
for like a military Commendation like a
achievement of some sort like the LI I'm
not I'm not in the military anymore but
like no but like the the the the
packager or something it's just a
dream Kennedy dude like what type of
face oh yeah you like special ops and
[__] in front like that though yeah
those guys those guys are really tough
I'm not well most gangster like sniper
type [__] I'm not good that good at
shooting dude those guys are crazy it's
a [__] fantasy you wouldn't want to
be famous for having like he didn't have
a fantasy I want my business to be good
go through Bart's last go through Bart's
last [__] 10 Instagram stories and
you know he doesn't try to show that
he's really hard like [__]
dancing by the pool and [__] he's not
like out there with sniper rifles and
like he's talking about like you know
the Integrity of man is like all about
is all based on like how much work you
and but that makes it even better that a
guy like that I was trying to make that
kind of content but it just didn't hit
right what what did you would did you
like it if you could retain your same
personality of like funny happy like
nice guy but then also on your record
that's the BART that rescued his whole
platoon dead you know what I mean like
like you you better respect that man son
you know like remember when when the
dude in in uh what was it in the
American Sniper goes to the auto shop
and the guy's like well sir oh you saved
my whole platoon like that you run into
people that you helped that would be
pretty cool be like no I didn't dude and
then you can still act like that do [__]
and every single one of these guys comes
up like ta's there too and it's just
like learning about your [__] heroism
indirectly dude n how you put TA in
there is different cuz you kind I think
every guy wants their son to think their
dad's badass yeah there's going to be a
moment when he thinks you're lame well I
think it's right now so far I don't
think it's like you think you're cool he
calls him Bart all my friends are
[__] stronger than me too so I'm like
hey you know Dad could [__] squat
like 500 lb and he's like well how about
him I why you asking questions like that
but Uncle NAD can do this much Uncle
squad's [__] 600 are you happy godle
Uncle doesn't have these two cool
swords that's true that's true that's
sick but he probably does look cooler
holding him real
M Like a Warrior yeah it looks like a
more of a comfortable dual wield you
just give up seems like because you've
been in in the marines that like you
know like every Marine has the capacity
to like save their whole [__] platoon
it's like a thing of like why not want
that right yeah why not want the you
also in boot camp and in the military
you learn about so many so you have like
War history and knowledge that you have
to learn yeah and everyone that saved
their platoon died yeah usually jumped
on a grenade oh you know so that's like
you you listen to it enough you're like
oh if I want to save my whole platoon
I'm going to have to jump on the grenade
or damn if I see the grenade
fall you got to kick it what are some
other ways it can get around I got two
nine iron got two seconds to think about
what I want to do pass night
iron
damn what were you going to say sir sir
no I'm not going to say
no